so 1-1 comments for the speakers is
please repeat questions when they're
gonna talk about categorical aspects of
compositionality right thanks a lot for
inviting me this is a perfect conference
for for what I want to think about these
days so I'm gonna say as you know as I'm
gonna talk about things that other
people have said and I'll just kind of
say them in a more theoretical or more
category theoretic way just because I
like that
and maybe I'll and yeah so I want to
kind of define what I mean by
compositionality before before we start
and I think we've already said it but I
want to say it kind of more formally so
so what I mean by composition I work a
lot with engineers and I want to use the
word composition the way that they use
the word composition so I mean
assembling many things together to make
one thing so we'd say that Y is composed
of some pieces that are assembled
together and blue it means things and
red means arrangements and green means
nesting so all this had that color
coding because they say color on slides
is nice so so we have these we have
pieces x1 through xn and we're we're
going to specify how they're arranged to
create some kind of bigger thing Y and
we can arrange these nestings we can
nest these arrangements inside of each
other so this natural naturally leads to
this notion of an opera or multi
category and an opera specifies what are
the things we're going to be talking
about what are the arrangements by which
one thing is composed of many things and
how does nesting work and so those are
the objects the morphisms in the
composition formula of the of the Opera
and by the way when I say opera at I
mean what's usually called a color
topper ad it has lots of different
objects not just one it could have one
obviously also called a multi category
or a symmetric multi category
I like up red coats small and sounds
like operation and and I usually think
of algebra of these things which is what
operators were invented for words for
kind of cataloguing algebra is of
something so so just to picture what
these look like the diagrams I like to
draw often look like this and this is an
arrangement Z is formed as an
arrangement an assembly of things y1 and
y2 where y1 and y2 are each arrangements
of smaller things x1 through whatever
and so in the operatic picture people
usually draw arrows like this so this is
a multi arrow from X 1 1 X 1 2 X 1 3 2 y
1 but if you kind of turn that from
being left to right into being inside
and outside x11 you know these guys are
inside of y1 and these guys are inside
of y2 and in the way Peter May who
invented out Brad's talked about the
little cubes operatic cetera it's the
same kind of picture you're seeing there
it's just that now we're wiring them
together and that wiring together is
what we mean by the morphism in the
upper ed so the nesting says you can put
you know this Y box is actually just a 1
into out box and and so it - no I'm not
saying something very understandable at
this point but but I'm trying to say
that I'm arranging things inside of
bigger things and you can nest them and
compose them and this is this is an
opera this is a picture of an opera a
very specific operative wiring diagrams
so an opera specifies a theory of
composition what are we going to be
composing and how do we arrange them
there are these sorts and operations of
a theory of composition this is I think
Gordon also pointed this out when he
said you know in my theory likes is not
part of the not part of the theory of
composition and your in your theory it
is so choosing your opera at is choosing
what you mean by composition
funk toriel semantics is that a model of
this up rad is a functor from o2 set or
I mean Gordon said to anything else
sometimes I'd like to send them to set
or cat or but some semantic space where
they'd have a lot of freedom so to every
sort in your op rad for everything for
every type of thing you have all the
things of that sort that's the set that
an object goes to and for every
arrangement in your op ad you have a
function that takes a thing of sort one
a thing of sort to and a thing of sort N
and produces a thing of sort Y according
to that arrangement and that's just a
functor from o to set so given a tuple
of things and a rule for assembling them
you obtain a new thing and so this is
what I mean by composition and I I think
it's a very standard way of saying what
composition is I just wanted to say it
explicitly as explicitly as possible so
what do I mean by compositionality I
think it's a well-known term and and
maybe many people have defined it and I
just wanted to define it again what I
mean by it to make sure that it's the
same my my dad always told me that
Einstein said if you don't know
something say aloud so I don't know how
well known you know what we all mean by
composition and and I want to say what I
mean and here you know responses to that
so an attribute so what when I when I
say something is compositional what kind
of thing can be compositional to me it's
an attribute of something that could be
compositional we're looking at some
system we're trying to analyze it we're
talking to I'm often talking to
scientists or engineers they want to
understand something they didn't before
they want to analyze something so you
want to be able to say well if you
analyze it this way you're going to be
able to compose those analyses together
so an attributes like a projection onto
a simpler space like an attribute of an
ordinary difference equation or a open
dynamical system or something is it's
that set of steady states so you've
taken something complex like an ordinary
differential equation and you've mapped
it onto a simpler space that's an
attribute I'm just trying to define
words here so an attribute of a function
one attribute is
you injective or not so we're projecting
all of functions set of functions onto
the set of boolean x' but when when is
some an attribute compositional it's
when it's when it you have a what
natural transformation of functors so
I'm trying to say mathematically what we
could mean by that so we have this
compositional theory oh and we have this
model M or algebra of Oh from it tells
us what the things of each sort are and
we have a system of attributes for this
thing so for every we have a simpler
space in another model and every sort we
have an attribute that takes the more
complex stuff too the more simple stuff
and the compositionality aspect of it
which Gordon also wrote in his talk and
it is just that you know this commutes
its natural transformation that if you
take things x1 through xn and you
compose them according to arrangement
Phi in the model and then you analyze
that big system which is very complex
that you could have done it an easier
way you could have taken each thing and
analyzed it found that simpler attribute
and then compose those attributes
together so when someone says is the
thing you know is this the whole of some
of its parts
they're asking well oftenly I think they
were asking if I don't know Phi can I
figure out can I analyze my big system
from my parts and that's the answer is
no if you don't know the interactions
between your things it's very rare that
you're going to be able to analyze a big
thing by just knowing quantities applied
to each of the small things how many of
this organelle is in my cell or
something I mean you have to know kind
of how things are arranged but I think a
question that we it almost is the
definition of a model is that if you're
modeling something and you like your
model then you better say that the
interactions you're thinking about and
the things you're thinking about and the
analysis work together in this way so
compositionality just says that two
things are the same you can either
compose the pieces in the complex space
and then project via the attribute or
you can project the ID attribute and
then come
according to your arrangement so let me
give two example this one I'll talk
about in more depth and then up the
other one I'll just pass through
so taking steady states is a
compositional analysis of dynamical
systems so there's an opera ad for
composing dynamical systems it's almost
there almost like a traced cat trace
monoidal category but there's an opera
at whose whose pictures look like this
whose morphisms look like this and there
is a model or a functor or an algebra
from w to set that asks that puts in
each box any dynamical system and then
composes them to create a dynamical
system in the outer holes and I'll
define dynamical systems later so the
question was do I mean to have feedback
and I definitely mean to have feedback
in this diagram where information is
flowing out of x-5 and back into X 4 or
other information that's flowing out of
X 5 and back into X 1 so yes I
definitely mean that ok and what I'll
talk about later is that there's a
compositional analysis from one model of
this opera to another model of this
opera one model is dynamical systems can
go in each box and another opera another
model that doesn't feel like it has
feedback at all it is putting matrices
into each box if you put matrices in X 1
and X 2 you might be able to multiply
them but what happens when you have all
this complex stuff you can also there's
a model of matrices for this type of
string diagram and I'm going to talk
about that and the point is that there's
an analysis or a way of looking at
dynamical systems which is which
produces a matrix out of any dynamical
system and those that that analysis is
compositional you can you can know the
steady states of the whole dynamical
system by composing matrix wise the
steady states of the pieces
and by steady-state someone else said
the word fixed points and that's the
same word and equilibria that's the same
word not the same word same meaning okay
example two I'm just going to pass
through this one there's an opera at
four composing hierarchical protein
materials so I just wanted to kind of
give the breath of what I mean by a prat
using op rads for talking about
composition so what is a protein it's an
arrangement of simpler proteins and what
is a protein well so there are our
atomic proteins in the you know operatic
theories you don't need a base level but
if you have one then then well typically
scientists have liked those historically
and philosophers I guess you know they
like to have basic stuff so so of amino
acids are the basic ones and protein
materials can be are very you know
complex things they include your skin
and with molecular dynamic simulator z'
you can make an actual model of of this
algebra so what can you do you can
assemble a new protein from a set of
other proteins by assembling them in
series like popping those amino acids
together or in parallel or arranging
them in HeLa C's so if you have some
library of proteins you've already made
you could take the ones and attach them
together or you could you know bend them
into some spirals so this is like a
helix of HeLa C's each one of these guys
is bending and we just made this little
picture by plopping it in you know
flopping some some amino acids into this
this kind of operatic protein about
programming language now if you had a
compositional analysis of this would be
incredibly useful incredibly because I
would find it pretty incredible that you
could actually do that but it'd be great
if you could assign to each amino acid
or each protein a strength or a
toughness or whatever people study in
material science and then when you
compose them by attaching or putting
them in parallel you'd have a formula
that told you an expected strength or
toughness of the new material people I
mean I think this would be kind of the
holy grail of material science or of
protein material science and even if it
wasn't perfectly a compositional I think
that'd be a very a very valued valued
thing to have it tells you that you can
guess what you're going to get
strength-wise by by looking at the
strength of the pieces and how they fit
together
so in this talk I'm going to talk about
operas of string diagrams because I
guess for me composition in my history
started with composition in the category
so I'm going to talk about category
theory and different what I call
doctrines I haven't found a good name
for these things some people call them
notions of monoidal category that's what
Peter Salinger calls him because I
looked to him to tell me what to call
these things but I'm gonna talk about
opera heads form on roids and categories
and trace monoidal categories and hyper
graph categories with which Brendan will
talk about later and then I'll talk I'll
talk about the steady states of
dynamical systems and and finally
conclude with a few more words on
compositionality or what happens when
you don't have it ok so do I stop at
11:30 or 11:35 so string diagram
diagrams are attributed to Penrose and
jowl Street Verity other people they
give us a visual tool for solving an
algebra problems you can look at you can
look at the algebra problem in a string
diagram language and and guess well you
know you can use your visual system to
answer questions but not whether to to
morphisms are equal for example so how
do i brad's come into play we can
organize the string diagrams for one of
these doctrines as an opera oh so the
connection between the string diagrams
and their meaning is this functor from o
to set so here's an example of a string
diagram for crepes monoidal categories
in any trace monoidal category where you
each of these would be filled within a
morphism
each string would have a label on it
that told you what the objects coming in
and the objects coming out are
so and and one of these would denote a
morphism in that monoidal category and
that trace monoidal category but what is
this picture as a mathematical object
you could say it's I forget some kind of
graph
I forget how joy Allen Street and Verity
described it but some kind of graph
embedded in to RN but it's there are
simpler ways of talking about it and so
let me start easy with the string
diagrams for monoids using the operatic
language so it's it's well known that
the terminal Opera at T is the theory of
MA nodes the terminal Opera at has one
object which I'll just draw with a box
with two lines coming out of it and it
has one n area more present for any N
and I'll draw that as just how many
boxes I put inside of one box so if I
want to put three boxes inside of one
box this is the only way to draw it that
there's one of those and so a model of T
whenever I say a model of I supposed to
be a script T whenever I say a model of
an opera or an algebra I mean a functor
to set at least today so it assigns to
the unique object of the Opera add a set
which is your monoi de ella mints a set
of elements of your mon wood and it
assigns to the unique n area of
operation a single function from M times
M times M to M and the composition
formula of T ensures the associativity
and u totality of your MA node so we can
think of this as kind of an unbiased
perspective on MA nodes in the sense
that instead of thinking about two
generators for mono is namely we have a
unit we have a multiplication and we
have some rules about associativity
so that's generators in relations
approach it's kind of an unbiased
approach in that it puts all the
operations whether it's 1 or 2 or 3
multiplying 1 or 2 or 3 or n things
together on equal footing now unbiased
sounds good like everyone should be
unbiased but does it that's not true you
don't have to be unbiased you can have
biases it's very convenient for
calculation to have by
but if sometimes good to be able to be
unbiased also so I'm not trying to use
that as a positive word I'm just trying
to use it as a descriptive word string
diagrams focus on morphisms not objects
so to talk about what a category is from
this perspective it's going to be a mono
I'd plus labels and the labels are going
to be kind of the objects or types the
labels and types that I mean the same
thing by label and type so the downside
that I find with using op Brad's and
doesn't hit hit very often but things
the thing it makes a little harder to
advertise is that they're parametric on
objects in a way that I'm not very happy
with so there's no operate for
categories there's lots of operates for
lots of categories in the sense that if
you fix your object set lambda then
there's an opera or lambda categories
categories whose objects are lambda so I
haven't really settled on a way of
dealing with this in a nice way because
I really like the Opera operatic
approach for string diagrams but I don't
like that I have to be parametric and in
the objects but let's just choose my set
of objects lambda or labels or types
define a lambda as the following up Brad
its objects are pairs of types that are
going to stand as the domain and
codomain of a morphism and the N area
operations are just tuples of labels
such that the you know x0 x1 is a labels
for x1 and x1 x2 is label for x2 etc and
Y is the outer labels x0 x3 so it says
that if I have a sequence of morphism I
mean in semantics it says if I have a
sequence of morphisms such that the
domains and Co domains match up
correctly then I can compose them so
again it's kind of an unbiased approach
to instead of having just a two area and
a zero area composition a unit and a
multiplication there's an N area
multiplication so kind of there's a more
interesting or more kind of interesting
connection that comes about for traced
monoidal categories which are that they
have to do with
kind of like teak you have to use
although I'm always saying that because
I've met someone who thinks about tqf
teas but in other words functors from
cob the category of co board isms
oriented cavort isms to set so
forgetting about string labels because
they just kind of complicate the
you know they add up they had one extra
bit of notation functors from the
category of co board isms two sets zero
one one co board isms to set is
equivalent to trace to annoyed 'l
categories so if you're allowed to draw
diagrams like this and compose morphisms
in a tres monoidal category what are
diagrams like this they are co board
isms this is a picture of a keyboard
isms just drawn in a different way how
does that work a co board ism as one co
board ism is a courtesan between 2 to 0
2 oriented 0 manifolds and a 0 manifold
is a signed set it's a finite set of
pluses and minuses so x1 here is two
minuses and a plus x2 is 1 plus and 2 1
minus in two pluses and y is two minuses
and two pluses and so I've you know
knowing that x1 a is attached to X to B
as you can see here and knowing knowing
all of this stuff is just drawing a co
board ism
another doctrine that seems to be useful
in application is hypergraph categories
and I find the usual definition of
hypergraph category to be a bit involved
it's a symmetric monoidal category C in
which each object is equipped with the
structure of a Montoya and a comb on
Royd and they satisfy a bunch of
additional axioms but it's really easy
from string diagram perspective you're
just wiring together little circles
inside a bigger circle so you draw these
hyper graphs the the objects are X or
the nodes or X 1 X 2 X 3 and there is
hyper edges which are shown with these
little links these little dots there
there's a one area hyper edge there's a
three area hyper edge that connects
things and in fact this is a picture of
a coast fan so in the last in the last
slide I was saying this is a picture of
a this is a picture of a co Board ism
and now I'm saying this is a picture of
a coast ban so what's the coast fan I
have set X 1 which is a 3 element set X
2 is just a 3 element set X 3 is a 4
element set X 4 is a 2 element set and
why the outer thing is a 3 element set
just the number of ports and so I have a
coast fan from that kind of union of
sets to the set of links here every port
is being attached to one link
think you have links and don't get hit
Brendan and Alex Kissinger say no and I
say I don't care so so can a hyper edge
be incident to zero vertices thank you
you made my flight relevant if yes then
you're working with coast bands if no
you're working with Co relations you're
saying they're jointly surjective maps
so what are examples of hypergraph
categories Baez and Fung have passive
linear circuits as a functor from this
operetta set H is just it H is just Co
span so H shouldn't look complicated the
category of relations is is hypergraph
category the category of arrays or
tensors is a hypergraph category you can
compose arrays together to get make a
new array and I'll be talking about that
later with the dynamical systems so if
you have any semi ring k then arrays
with entries in K will form a functor
from H to set a model of this theory of
composition so I don't know if this is
really worth saying really carefully so
if you're little so in these pictures
here you have you have little cells with
ports and we're gonna wire them together
so given a cell with ports that's X it's
got not only a set of ports but it's
also got a label for each port namely a
finite set of indices for your array so
suppose suppose you had two ports and on
port 1
you had the number m and on port 2 you
had the number n so you have a circle
with two lines coming off it labeled m
and n then by x-bar I just mean M times
n and array X is functions from M times
n to your semi-ring K so it just fills
in every entry with a value and then for
any coast band like this there's an
array multiplication formula given an
array here and a right here and right
here and right here you can multiply
them in some kind of obvious way
and get an array for the outside thing
so here's some examples of well-known
operations they were not well known to
me but they're well known to people so
matrix multiplication corresponds to
this wiring diagram what's called Katri
Rao multiplication that's when I didn't
know before corresponds to this wiring
diagram the trace of a matrix where you
have an M by an N by n matrix you can
just find a 1 by a 1 dimensional matrix
there you can do the Hadamard product
with this wiring diagram you can do the
Kronecker product with this wiring
diagram or you can take your matrix and
kind of add up along the rows or along
the columns with this wiring diagram
people called if these people call these
for products but they don't call these
products products maybe because there's
only one ok thanks I learned something
so what's the real role of op rads in
all this what I was talking about his
string diagrams and how for every string
diagram there's an opera at O and the
opera just allows you to change the
string a functor between a Brad's allows
you to change the string diagram type so
if you know that every string diagram of
type 1 that opera apps in this opera of
type 2 then you get in the junction
between models of 1 and models of the
other now working with the doctrines
directly is often preferable to using
opera ads working with traced monoidal
categories is often preferable to
working with cob algebras because people
understand it faster or more used to it
we can calculate with those with those
things you don't have to worry about
object labels which as I said annoys me
but another another thing there are
reasons to prefer oper ads namely you're
not restricted to looking at these named
doctrines like trace monoidal categories
you can look at any string diagram
calculus you can think of so trace
categories without identities come up
for me in dynamical systems but how do
you define the trace category without
identities most of the axioms use the
identities to define them but it's
perfectly natural to write down what the
op-ed looks like it's actually pretty
I'll talk about in the next slide a
little bit and and it's you know an
unbiased thing and another thing I like
about it is that engineers which I work
with scientists and engineers a lot they
they seem to find the perspective of
building one thing for many compelling
so if you do want to work with someone
outside of math I think that that it's
it's a convenient way of talking with
people yeah okay so what are dynamical
systems
Prakash talked about them but they're
cysts they're machines that take an
input like through your eyes and ears
change their state according to the
input they receive and according to the
state they were already in like if I'm
sad and I see something I'm different
than if I'm happy and I see the same
thing I changed my state and then I
produce outputs and I express myself
through my motor system or through just
some wires coming out and and I send
signals on so usually dynamical systems
come in one of two flavors actually
three discrete continuous or hybrid but
we'll talk about discrete and continuous
today and all of our open all of our
stein amical systems are open systems
they can interact with other systems so
if you have a pair of sets say manifolds
or sets I would draw all the dynamical
systems that can fit in this box are
those that take in inputs from X in and
spit out outputs and X out what is the
discrete dynamical system it's a set or
manifold of states it's an update
function that takes in an old state and
input and gives you a new state or takes
an old state and an input and gives you
a tangent direction like some ordinary
differential equation so when I say
discrete dynamical says when I say
continuous dynamical systems these are
kind of open ordinary differential
equations that have taken input and give
that output the output function is here
sometimes called the read out function
so dynamical systems can be composed
almost like in a trace category but not
quite because if you allow identities
you can't have feedback and if you have
feedback you can't have identities or if
you want both then you don't have
totality you get kind of a partial thing
and so I think this is related to the
the trace ideals actually I'm pretty
sure it's related to traced ideals of a
Bram Sookie blue and pen on Gooden
so something like this should be true
I've talked with Rick about it and we
both believe it but we haven't proved it
formally that if you have any symmetric
monoidal category see there's an opera
at all call it W sub C with the
following properties the category of
traced ideals in C or the way that trace
ideals compose the traced ideals in C
are the functors from W to set and not
only that but W C is the left class of a
factorization system on cob so it's
basically these cob diagrams but not all
of them so dynamical systems form a
traced ideal in the sense letting W be
the a Brad W sub set or W sub manifolds
a discrete dynamical system or
continuous dynamical system as a functor
or algebra or Model W to set the wiring
diagrams look like this the only thing
I'm not showing here is one word that's
a passing wire and so that's exactly
what the traced ideals or at least the
way I conceptualize it are avoiding is
and they're that they're actually
avoiding any function from from the
their mail I think they're mainly
avoiding the identities so they're
avoiding these passing wires and that's
the kind of thing I don't allow in these
pictures on the left class of a
factorization system eliminates those oh
wow I'm really behind
ok so steady states are a compositional
analysis means that dynamical systems
form a model we already said that and
there's a compositional analysis that
asks for the steady states
so my matrices are valued in 0 and 1 or
other caves other some rooms could also
work but by the steady state of a
dynamical system
I mean you pick an input you pick an
output of that system and you ask are is
there a steady state
is there a state such that the update of
that state at that input is the same
state is there a fixed point and is it
reading out why and that arranges your
steady States into a matrix and you can
compose those matrices
according to matrix arithmetic according
to the wiring diagram if if you're in a
if you're in a continuous system such a
matrix is called the bifurcation diagram
of your system so if you have a
differential equation or a dynamical
system you can write what's called the
bifurcation diagram and compose those
according to matrix arithmetic to get
the bifurcation diagram of the whole
system okay so just to this just says
the same thing again so I can take my up
red one
I have a functor to up rad - that kind
of takes you know the same boxes with a
different like kind of a simpler way of
looking at them and there's a
steady-state analysis that's a natural
transformation from one to another so
all I want to say in this slide is that
some weak an analysis is compositional
if you get an isomorphism between
analyzing and composing but a generative
effect would be one where you don't get
to know that true analysis of the model
from analyzing the pieces and that comes
from a kind of in exactness of the yeren
a your analysis and and a colleague of
mine at MIT has a coma logical theory of
these generative effects that allows you
to understand what's going on in in the
big model in terms of collage achill
aspects of the pieces so I think that's
pretty mean but I I don't just to
summarize I talked about
compositionality building one thing out
of many it'd be amazing to have a
compositional analysis of materials and
we can describe string diagrams with
with upper ads and we can we can think
about dynamical systems in terms of
steady states using there's a functor
that that does that and I say thank you
[Applause]
hi I have a question I wanted to know
whether what influenced this
presentation has on the inverse problem
which is for example so here you have a
bunch of pieces you know either
connected you get a result and if you
know less about some of the pieces you
can away a range of possible results
right what happens if you now say you
know the end result but you don't know
some of the pieces can you go back and
fill in the missing pieces
so we asked this is saying if you have
if you know a system how its composed
and you know something about each piece
you can figure out something about the
the hole and and then the question is if
you want to know something about the
hole can you figure out something about
how they're connected so it's like the
inverse public are you going to fill in
those details if you know what the
system is I certainly don't have a
theory of how you can fill in the
details of the of the missing parts
knowing the knowing the hole and and
something about how they're arranged but
you would sometimes I think of this as
kind of like the question of you know
how to multiply but what you really want
to know is how to factor factoring is
hard multiplying is easy and but you
couldn't factor if you didn't know what
multiplication meant so at least I'm
this is that that's kind of how I would
summarize your question and I would say
no factoring is hard I guess or whatever
I mean it can be done but you have to be
clever yeah
I was good to see that there is computer
science idea down design for you have a
system and analyze it into these fine
approach is there any sound correctly
that you are proposing you have a
diagrammatic way of understanding crazy
ideas
oh yeah yes I think so
I'd like to trace on anything that's in
the traced ideal you can then you can't
yeah
yeah you keep so what what you're
allowed to put in a box
oops I went the wrong way that was what
you're allowed to put in a box here is
exactly the types of things that can be
traced and what you're allowed to put on
the wire is anything the strings are so
this box has on this left and honestly
right say it has an object two objects
and this box has two objects and on this
string is a morphism in your category
but what you're allowed to put in a box
is something in the traced ideal I
wanted to ask you sort of along the
lines of Dana's question whether there
is a way at the level of the string
diagrams to understand feedback fixed
points is there a way to unfold the
diagrams to understand the behavior of
fixed points
do feel a little so you asked is there a
way to think about or understand the
feedback and how it relates to fixed
points and the fixed points right so
it's I'm not sure exactly what to say
one thing I've said here was that fixed
points or steady states are a
compositional analysis in other words
there is a functor that takes any
dynamical system and returns its
feedback returns its fixed points as a
matrix and that is compositional in the
sense that you can understand the fixed
points of the whole system by composing
the matrices of the fixed points of the
pieces but I'm not sure if that's what
you were asking I was asking more in
terms of having some reflection in this
formalism or to say the stages of the
computation of the fixed point right
right because usually when people talk
about fixed points in your Center in a
sense you're talking about they're
talking about the actual computation as
a whole and not the fixed points of some
dynamical system I would I would guess
that there's a way you know we could if
we talked about it we could find
something but but I think I think there
is I mean this the fixed points instead
of thinking about these things as
updating a state one at a time the fixed
points are involved in thinking about
the entire hist map from histories to
histories and it's a fixed point in that
kind of place is that is that that sound
reasonable okay well we could talk about
it basically the fixed points that
people usually talk about in be decides
the setting is Cartesian
okay just wanted to have one one sort of
translational remark but I think your
view of compositionality is very very
much of a allied nature to what people
talk about in if he decides but with a
slightly different language I mean
nothing attributes people would say
properties representing on from the
semantics being compositional people are
very interested in compositional methods
of reasoning about systems and I think
that's where the connection is very
direct and going to simplify offals
more effective reasoning yeah I would
like to have the right terms to to
connect in with the with the existing
literature so Thanks something about
traces and identities don't oh yeah
so I said he John asked I said that
trace in in a dynamical system you can't
have identities and traces and feedback
and without partiality it's like
something right and so I guess the point
is that if my input is if my output is
directly affecting my input with no time
delay between them and my input is
affecting my output with no time delay
then that becomes an equation to solve
that f of X y equals x or something and
so you lose the fact that you are I mean
then only solutions that equation will
satisfy the wiring diagram
so if your is a lottery input of some
bigger system would give an output only
the ones that made someone that made
input equal output right because you're
putting input into output and there's no
time delay right
[Applause]